bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono pochi j
oggi siamo su baby blues che spero non
sia una marca di pannolini ma non credo
ed è appunto da parte di scherzi e un
indie horror che mi avete consigliato in
tantissimi è però non idea di che parla
so solo che mi avete consigliato
veramente in tanti è dato che io non è
che sia molto contento di andare a
giocare sta roba
non faccio lo stesso perché mi avete
consigliato in tanti in genere i
videogame che mi consigliate veramente
in tanti li faccio sempre
è questo qui appunto uno degli ultimi
che è praticamente mi avete consigliato
non so di che parla non so come si gioca
non so una ceppa di minchia però vabbè
andiamo a vedere insieme anche se voi
non sapete di che cosa si tratta non lo
so neanche io quindi
[Musica]
questo è il nuovo singolo di rihanna su
itunes molto orecchiabile o perfetto
siamo partiti non so dove perfetto che
bello una stanza gigantesca mi chiama
quante grossa madonna hanno fatto un po
il soffitto alto ragazzi mi dicono ah no
forse perché sono io un tappo allora
laga
i casi sono due o il soffitto è alto 12
metri ho io sono un nano da giardino
però vabbè hanno forse non ha forse se
non neonato a giudicare dalla stanza in
cui sono partito forse sono un neonato
che gattona bello leonina in the deep
tethis first devo raccogliere gli
orsacchiotti ma stiamo scherzando cosa
un mattarello che è bello sono al
neonato perché hanno fatto allora forse
vi faccio ancora la popolato e probabile
è apparso una mano rossa perché sa
perché
madonna non ci sono andato un a
sportellate in faccia perfetto
siamo partiti benissimo la porta la
chiudo si bene bene dove stiamo andando
in giro per casa mamma che cos'è sta
roba perché c'è un distributore di acqua
in casa non ci hanno un lavandino
va beh non importa poche domande oddio
raga ma e questa è quella di witch
quella che quando non guardi ti ti ti
viene addosso perfetto
questa è chiusa credo sì c'è anche
scritto k perché gestito k se prendo
capano funziona
vabbè sarà chiusa torniamo più tardi
comunque c'è la tipa di di which he
stavolta nomi forti
la stronza che invece mi ha fatto
veramente una paura assurda
ok c'è il corridoio c'è ho sentito un
rumore bruttissimo che non mi è piaciuto
per niente ma noi proseguiamo questo che
cosa mi deve rappresentare cos'è la
poltrona no un qualche tipo di di
qualcosa non so cosa vedo qualcosa che
spunta raga ma lo vedete anche voi
qualcosa che spunta dall'angolo ma che
cazzo è ok io io non ci vado non ci vado
lì entro qui dentro
chiudi chiudi chiudi imperfetto bene
siamo nel bagno non so dove di preciso
beh bello bello il bagno bellissimo anno
gli scarichi del cesso automatici o c'è
qualcuno di invisibile è inquietante sta
cosa parecchio
vabbè lasciamo perdere oddio cos'è
questo una chiave ma hamas rom che
perfetto parola di prendere tech ma solo
un che gli ok ci siamo ci siamo abbiamo
la chiave della distanza dalla mamma
l'unico problema è che sono talmente
nano che non arrivò alle maniglie cioè
non so come fa ad aprire la porta però
va beh intanto laggiù c'è sempre
qualcosa che dondola e non so che cos'è
però prima cos'è questo c'è norma con
tre dita è il bigfoot che non idea di
che cosa sia però non mi piace noi
andiamo ovunque meno che laggiù quindi
prima di andare laggiù devo provare a
vedere se la stanza della mamma è questa
porca [ __ ] che cazzo è successo
la luce è saltata la luce è saldata alla
luce calmi e vabbè io prego che questa
sia la stanza della mamma perché laggiù
non ci voglio andare
se è questa e chiudi la porta
assolutamente chiudi chiudi chiudi vabbè
lasciamo che sia perfetto
s'è chiusa la sola va bene allora la
stanza della mamma a facebook sono
troppo piccolo per potermi fare un
account quindi come al solito non posso
controllare le notifiche al computer e
vabbè andiamo avanti
c'è una cyclette la mamma si tiene in
forma c'è take that di boe yes una sua
nave che cazzo era store umore
cos'era pianissimo andiamo pianissimo
c'era ho sentito un rumore bruttissimo
vabbè lasciamo perdere andiamo raga sono
costretto ad andare dove prima c'era il
braccio e lo vedo ancora ok piano
ragazzi c'è qualcosa c'è qualcosa laggiù
c'è qualcosa non lo vede
ma lo vedete anche voi ma che cazzo ma è
andato è andato via
c'era qualcuno qui prima lo giuro
l'avete visto
non dite che sono pazzo perché l'ho
visto allora raga mi mancano questa età
intanto all'entrata principale va non
penso di riuscire ad aprirla sono più
piccolo del sole più piccolo del
tappetino di ingresso e vabbè mi mancano
8 teddy bear non ho preso niente
praticamente ok 222 prendi lo stronzo
prendi o se devono per forza fare stiro
mari della minkia ogni volta che prendo
un orsacchiotto perché non lo so mi
spiazza ogni volta
comunque siamo a 2 su 9 che veramente
pochissimo però vabbè già qualcosa
ora i ragazzi chiuso tutto qua questa
purtroppo ancora non l'ho provato ad
aprire però è chiuso tutto quanto laga
tranne forse sta infatti sta porta
aperta e lo studio di papà ho sentito
anche un rumore e lo studio del babbo
che ha la mia stessa sedia
vabbè di grafici che cazzo ci sono in
grado che cazzo è chi cazzo era chi
cazzo era quella era la testa della
which c'è qualcosa qui il teddy bear
prendilo 369 non mi ha [ __ ] stavolta
lo sapevo me lo immaginavo maniera noi
siamo vicini merda
usciamo di quadri armiera state vicini
state vicini voi tra di voi però perché
io non di quella [ __ ] [ __ ]
ok
ma lasciamo stare
lasciamo stare ci mancava soltanto uno
screen da ma fatemi capire ma mi state
prendendo per il culo c'è ma voi state
ascoltando quello che dicono perché
veramente sembra una presa per il culo
vabbè saporta abbiamo detto che chiusa
ho aperto tutte le porte
diciamo che si potevano aprire fino a
parte questa ok casa roma c'è una
macchia sul muro
va beh non voglio sapere che cos'è vabbè
lasciamo perdere
chesta porta che non ho aperto intanto
continua a darmi le sportellate in
faccia ma facciamo finta di niente media
room non ed eric e che tipo di stanza
sia non ho mai sentita sento delle voci
perfetto c'è un cavallo a dondolo
fantasma c'è anche il teddy bear
perfetto siamo a 4 e poi oltre a quello
non c'è niente mi servirebbero delle
chiavi possibilmente perché se no non
posso andare nelle altre porte però le
chiavi non le trovo
ma che cazzo ma se un due ore che cerco
sta merda di chiave ed era qui ma dai
c'è ma vabbè lasciamo perdere sono due
ore che cercavo stava le detta chiave in
giro per casa e poi era di bella
tranquilla sul davanzale che mi stava
dicendo non ora prendimi favi invece
niente
tra l'altro per l'emozione non ho
neanche letto di che minchia era sta
chiave però vabbè una chiave
apriamo le porte chiuse proviamo questa
perfetto l'ho aperta la stanza della
lavatrice washroom fantastico la porta
si è chiusa qui dentro che cosa ci
dovrei mai trovare non lo so
proviamo a togliere teddy bear a
perfetto quasi un'altra chiave che la
chiave della cucina da cucina perfetto
intanto ma sto sbagliando io ho questa
prima non c'era forse mi sbaglio è
perché c'è una memoria talmente di merda
che sono capace di sbagliarmi ok ma che
cazzo è successo è andato a finire sotto
il pavimento ok ho fatto letteralmente
sprofondare una sedia a rotelle va bene
così
andiamo in cucina anche se non so dove
si trova proviamo la prima stanza chiusa
che mi viene in mente che è questa qui
continua benedetto santissimo
abbi pietà di noi con sti spaventi del
cazzo di dove entrare pure qui dentro
fantastico ragazzi cioè epico cucina
bellissima mamma mia che ordina salvo
no
a spegnere le luci così non ok perfetto
non ho appena finito di dire a spegnere
le luci che si riaccendono benissimo
mica posso spostare una donna ma è
questo qua è un che da piccolo cioè non
lo so mica sposta qualsiasi cosa
vabbè c'è scelta di ben 7 su 9 ok ok
devo riuscire a devo riuscire a fare due
cose almeno a finire il gioco o riuscire
a prepararmi al biberon language non so
ben bambino che si prepara seguici non
ho mai visto sinceramente
poi vabbè poi qualcuno mi spiega che
cazzo di omogenizzato li danno perché
riesce a spostare i tavoli a guardare e
assurdo però vabbè c'è una scritta sul
muro bye bye mama chiama ma cos'è questo
the di ben 8 su 98 98 su 98 fottuti
teddy bear su nove
ok mi dovete spiegare ora che cosa
minchia dovrei fare
sembrava uno di quei giocattoli di toy
story avete presente quelli che si
muovono è riuscito ad aprire la porta
male detto ok perfetto io preferivo
mister potato però va bene anche questo
c'è qualcuno nella stanza di papa c'è
qualcuno nella stanza di papà quella
sedia
[Musica]
permesso stai mica smantellando il muro
vero
[Musica]
ma chi cazzo è questo
oddio ragazzi è entrato satana in casa
che cazzo qualcuno di voi mi spiega
perché entrato satana in casa sennò non
ha senso non ha senso c'è
mi scusi le preparo un panino se vuole
mi scusi dov'è dove cazzo andato dio ha
buttato a terra le sedie ma si fa così
in casa degli altri minchia che ospite
stupido sarai anche satana ma non si
buttano a terra di serie non si cammina
sui muri degli altri
ecco di sta bene fatemi uscire di qua
fatemi uscire di qua tra ist e sedie
allora sfondato la porta per entrare
sicuro mi spiegate perchè ancora in
piedi non si s ad russi ok raga ok calmi
calmi scelte di me
l'ultimo non è su 9 9 su 9 non ci posso
credere non avessi un nuovo e non ci
posso credere dobbiamo tornare
all'inizio raga all'inizio dove
[Musica]
dobbiamo muovere il culo e torna a fare
all'inizio è risolta la sedia è risolta
non c'è la prima non c'era
ok ragazzi ok ci sono se sì chiuditi
maledetta porta di merda chiuditi ok ci
sono ho finito ho finito non rompete le
palle tutti a nanna tutti han han ok ok
raga non fate mela leggere vi prego
risparmiate vista tortura nel leggere
l'inglese che mi spara una figura di
merda che la metà basta va bene così
ok raga abbiamo finito fortunatamente
non voglio aggiungere altro su sta roba
se devo essere sincero quando ero
piccolo così io giocavo con i lego ma
forse neanche ero talmente piccolo che
leggo meli mangiavo è di certo non
andavano in giro per caso a trovare
orsacchiotti comunque sono contento che
sia finito un grazie di cuore a chi me
lo ha consigliato sei stato molto
gentile
come al solito ragazza il video è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina facebook che trovate
come al solito in ogni mio video nella
descrizione
se non siete ancora iscritti scrivete
che ci vediamo un prossimo video bella
ragazzi